if you allow Ukraine to be carved up
is the independence of Any Nation
secured
I'd respectfully suggest the answer is
no that's why the United States will
continue to stand with the brave people
in Ukraine it's not only an investment
in Ukraine's future but in the future
every country
that seeks a world governed by basic
rules that apply equally to All Nations
and now Mr zielinski Goes to Washington
Ukraine's president is expected to meet
tomorrow with Congressional leaders
along with President Biden but he
doesn't really need to beg for money now
because the White House is already
committed to giving him a significant
package including one or two things that
Ukraine has gotten before Senator Josh
Hawley is going to be at the all Senator
meeting with zelensky and now he joins
me senator
are you going to just hand over the you
know Uncle Sam's wallet completely or is
he going to get cash in person from the
president like what's going on yeah you
know it wouldn't surprise me if Senator
stood and just handed him bales of cash
Laura as he came in listen not over my
vote though I mean not with my support
we shouldn't be spending a dime more on
Ukraine we need an accounting of every
dime that has been spent so far and I'm
just tired of hearing the president say
over and over that we've got to invest
this is an investment the future of
every nation what about our nation it's
not an investment in our future in our
people in our jobs that needs to be the
priority
well your colleague Lindsey Graham
um wants everyone to know what's really
at stake with this spending on Ukraine
watch
you'll be in another War
because Putin won't stop he'll go to
Moldova and other places
China will see this as a signal of
weakness so for all these people who say
we need to get out of Ukraine to be
tough on China
you're making the a fatal mistake
Senator how is America going further
into debt making us stronger against
China
yeah I have to say I just completely
disagree with Lindsey Graham there if
you want to deter China then get tough
with China slap tariffs on China bring
back our jobs from China stop them from
treating our laborers like slave labor
and labor and driving down our wages and
stealing our technology that's how you
get tough on China not by spending money
in Ukraine so I just I just don't get it
if you want to spend money in Ukraine
tell me why Ukraine is important don't
tell me it's about China that's in a
completely different hemisphere for
heaven's sakes I mean come on now let's
focus on the real issue here which is
that we need to invest in this nation
and we need to deter China and we're not
doing that by investing or spending
money in Ukraine well there's at least
one president out there who's actually
listening to what his people may be
saying about increasing Aid uh to
Ukraine and that's the Polish president
senator who said about Ukraine earlier
this week Ukraine is behaving like a
drowning person clinging to anything
available a drowning person is extremely
dangerous capable of pulling you down to
the depth simply drown The Rescuer
talking about that grain embargo fight
they're over but at some point the
American people will have their say on
this and four more years of Biden
without a doubt means four more years of
war for the United States does that what
is that what Americans want four more
years of war no it's not what they want
it's not what they need here's what I
heard just today Laura I heard brief by
the administration that this newest
request for 24 billion more dollars more
US Dollars it's not the end it's not
even close to the end they want us to be
writing checks to Ukraine direct to
their government forever year after year
hundreds of billions of dollars that is
ridiculous for what what's the strategy
what what what's the end game they don't
have one it is nothing but nation
building it is nothing but in failing to
invest in the United States Laura we
have to stop this it's crazy uh Senator
thank you so much good to see you
tonight we look forward to that meeting
tomorrow hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else